from doing thy pleasure on my holy day and
call the sabbath a delight the holy of the
lord honorable and shall honor him not doing
thine own ways not finding thine own pleasures
nor speaking thine own words then shalt thou
delight thyself in the lord and i will cause
thee to ride upon the high places of the earth
and feed with the heritage of thy father jacob
for the mouth of the lord hath spoken
it happy sabbath everyone god is good
and all the time it's an high honor for
me to stand before you and speak for god
i have given him my word that i will do the
very best i can that the message that i deliver
is delivered without damage and that it may
have its proper effect in the lives of those
who listened and applied we thank god in
this country despite the challenges we have
we still enjoy freedom of worship well we need
a louder amen than that people have given their
lives in order to receive and enjoy freedom
of worship don't wait until it's taken away
to say amen because one day it will be taken
away let me say that again in this country
known for religious tolerance this lamb-like
what's the next word it's a lamb-like beast
it looks like a lamb and speaks like dragon so
it's hard to believe that a nation known worldwide
for freedom of conscience will one day restrict
the conscience and remove freedom of worship but
that's what bible prophecy says so while it is
day let us do god's work the night cometh where
no man can work who is with us today you are
not the seventh-day adventist match your hand
where i see accusatory fingers pointing
but i don't see the victims where ah would you
kindly stand my brother give us your name please
hold on hold on hold on right to the back
name is what burnett brother brown how
are you nice to see you where are you from
d.c
okay all right well thank you very much for coming
and god bless you you may be seated brother brown
yes my brother you were standing just now give us
your name antonio virginia my mother's middle name
is antonia nice to see antonio god my middle name
is anthony which is the english version of antonio
okay all in the family anybody else you're not a
san diego would you stand and give us your name
say that again errol butler hello brother butler
where are you from you look like a nice man god
bless you brother god bless you god bless you yes
my sister what's your name kim butler well then
you have to be a good woman how do you do nice
to see you are you also from this area thanks for
coming may god bless you and bless your families
anybody else you're not a seventh-day adventist
all right god is good come on say it as though
he's been good to you god is good and all the
time my greetings to those who listening via the
internet we're very grateful for technology and i
pray that god will bless you super abundantly as
you listen with an open mind and a willing heart
to the word as it is spoken our subject for this
morning present truth in all ages what did i say
before i begin i'd like you to uh turn these
off you know how i am what's this what's that
what do we use for worship a bible okay you can't
take this in a courtroom i hope you know that
so we turn this off and we turn the bible on
wherever possible now if you're coming for the
first time you don't know how strange i am and
you didn't bring one of these well i understand
but if you can use this please use a bible the
second favor i ask of you is that you pray for me
while i speak all i want you to say is
lord put your words in that man's mouth
that request is based on jeremiah chapter 1 verse
9. which says for the final day of this revival
then the lord put forth his hand and touched my
mouth and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth and favor number three
please think as you listen isaiah 1 18 come now
let us reason together saith the lord let us pray
father in heaven thank you for life despite the
aches and pains the trials and tribulations we're
happy to be alive today we thank you for that
if we've sinned against you today god forgive us
jesus shed his blood and then rose from the dead
to make a vague forgiveness available to us
forgive us for his sake and also because you love
us father i desire to speak only your words and so
i'm asking you to remember the words of david in
2nd samuel 23 verse 2 the spirit of the lord spake
by me and his word was in my tongue put your words
in my tongue remember your promise to moses exodus
4 12 now therefore go and i will be with thy mouth
and teach you what thou shalt say tell me what
to say to god and bless my brothers and sisters
with comprehension that lies may change decisions
may be made bless those listened via the internet
father bless them greatly and bring them closer
to the cross save as many of us as will allow you
to save us in jesus name i pray let god's people
say amen and amen our subject present truth in all
ages it's about 12 30 i'll try to release you by
1 15 temperance in all things including preaching
let me tell you a couple of things about jesus
one man said to christ you know i'll follow you
christ said the [ __ ] the fowls of the air have
nests the foxes have what holes the son of man
hath not where to what lay his head jesus christ
will eat breakfast at your house lunch at hers and
separate his that's how he lived he had no house
of his own when he was dedicated in the temple of
jerusalem his parents brought turtledoves why they
were poor this means that poverty is not a sin
let me say one other thing christ did
not come to die because people are poor
as most television preachers will have you believe
because all they preach is what get rich
the problem with the world is not poverty
i'm not glorifying poverty i'm saying
the problem of the world is not poverty
christ did not die to make poor people rich
materially now christ went up into the temple to
speak once in john 7. you don't have to go there
and the bible says the jews marvel saying how
north this man letters having never learned
are you following me christ did
not attend harvard of his day
or the university of temple hills or any other
school christ was educated at his mother's knee
and by his father christ did not die because
people didn't graduate from high school
not having an academic degree is not a sin
are you with me all right christ
lived a life on this earth
he never married not being able to find a man
is not a sin now if you find one god bless you
but not being able to find a spouse is not a
sin christ did not die because people are single
because being single is not
a sin jesus had no children
not in jeremiah or daniel or paul as far as we
know of the three hebrew boys or john the baptist
it is not a sin not to have children christ
didn't die that every woman's womb might be opened
why did christ die give me one word sin
let me say these words carefully listen carefully
the only problem you and i
have finish my words is sin
the gospel is a very simple thing to understand it
has to be simple because the lord desires to save
how many people all people and some people are
highly educated very intelligent others are not
so intelligent if god desires to save everyone at
every level the method of salvation must be simple
what did christ say when he came to this earth
what was his message before we look at the message
of christ let's look at the message of a man
who was sent to prepare the way for christ give
me his name quickly john the baptist he was the
cousin of christ older than jesus by six months
let's go to matthew three we read from verse
one our subject present truth in all ages
matthew chapter three reading verse from
verse 1 we read 1 and 2 and i read from the
king james version of the bible and those of you
listening via internet i hope you have your bibles
nearby the bible says in those days came home
john the baptist preaching in the wilderness of
judea and saying what repent uh for the kingdom
of is at hand what was john's message repent
the kingdom of heaven is at hand what does
john mean or what did he mean by repent
turn away from that which brought christ to
this earth to die and to bleed and to suffer
and to have people spit in his face
and to have the soldiers punched him
while he was blindfolded and
then asked him who hit you
turn from that
he came to prepare the way of the
lord to make his path straight
now a straight path there's nothing confusing
about a straight path are you with me
a path like this you see eloise says the devil is
very sinuous and serpentine god comes from a to b
now go to matthew 4 remember john the
baptist prepared the way for jesus
that was his mission given to him by god the
father of christ if john the baptist prepared
the way for jesus jesus had to follow that way
anyone agrees with that all right matthew 4
reading verse 17 our subject present truth in
all ages it's 20 minutes to one read with me
from that time began jesus to up preach and
to say what repent why for the kingdom of
heaven is at hand does that remind you of
anything what john the baptist's message
he prepared the way and jesus came and walked
right in that way and his message was repent
but let's read matthew 4 17 again the time we'll
read it microscopically and see what we can deduce
from that time began jesus to say
repent why for the kingdom of heaven is at
hand what do you understand like from that time
that man came to the revival at temple hills and
from that time he gave up alcohol what do you
understand by that he gave it up and left it
now listen again from that time when he came
out of the pool he was baptized in chapter three
he was tempted in the wilderness chapter 4
verse 1 to 11. now in 17 he starts to preach
publicly the bible says from that time the
time he came out of that baptismal pool
and from the temptation he began to preach and to
say do you get the impression he only said it once
what impression do you get
that was his message repent
for the kingdom of heaven is at hand john
the baptist was told by god to preach repent
jesus christ was told by god to preach
repent now i say he was told by god let
me show you what i mean go to john
7. we'll read 14 to 16. john 7 14-16
and when i say read with me i really
mean it it's not a command it's a request
john 7 reading from verse 14 what is that saying
now by the midst of the feast jesus went up where
into the temple too and talked yeah he went up
into the temple to teach now next verse and the
jews stop the jews what they're marvel is saying
what how knoweth this man letters having never
learned and we talked about that earlier read
verse 16 as jesus answered them what does he say
my doctrine come on it's not mine keep reading but
his that sent me now put two and two together when
jesus said repent matthew 4 17 for the kingdom
of heaven is at hand what does that mean to you
whose message was he preaching
the message of the father
go to john 8.
john 8 we read 26 27 and 28.
present truth in all ages
when you found it amen read with me i have many
things to say and to judge of you but he that
sent me is and i speak to the world those things
which i have yes i only say what i got from god
they understood not that he spared them
of the father read verse 28 then say jesus
unto them when you have lifted up the son of man
then shall he know that i am he and that i what
do nothing of myself keep reading but as my
father have taught me come on i speak these things
i do nothing of myself as my father hath taught me
i speak these things you begin to
understand why i ask you to say
lord put your words in that man's mouth because
the father put his words where in jesus mouth
and if jesus needed that
you know how badly i need it
i do nothing of myself but as my father hath
taught me i speak these things go to john 10.
john 10 let's read from verse 16 our
subject present truth in all ages
when you found you say amen read with me a
familiar verse and other sheep i have which
are not of this fold them also i must bring and
they shall hear my voice and there shall be one
and one shepherd verse 17 therefore doth my father
love me why because i laid on my life that i might
yes now read verse 18. read on no man taketh it
from me but i lay down of myself stop now go into
microscopic mode and read the rest of 18. i have
power to lay down come on and i have power to
finish the verse this commandment
have i received of my father
the father told jesus when to die when together
i have power to what lay down let's die
i have power to take it up he meant
authority this commandment have i received
of my father by the way there's several verses in
the new testament that suggests that say outright
the father raised jesus they saved them but you
need to understand that in the context of the
fact that the father told jesus when to get up
are you following me but jesus raised himself
he raised himself but at the command of the
father and so the father takes credit for the
obedience of his son so the bible says the father
raised him but the father raised him in the sense
that he came up when the father told him to
come up if someone else had raised jesus jesus
would not have conquered death the person
who raised him would have conquered death
we need a savior who of himself conquers death and
so the bible says in hebrews 1 3 when he had by
himself purged our sins and to purge sins you've
got to die and get up because the dead jesus
cannot save him so those who say the death of
christ was all that's needed for the atonement
they're dead wrong he had to rise and apply the
merits of that sacrifice and so jesus says i do
only what my father tells me i say only what
my father tells me to say let's go to john 14.
present truth in all ages
you see how remarkable the book of john is
all these texts that prove the father told
jesus what to say all found in the book of
john john specializes in talking about the
relationship between the son and the father
read that book sometimes your life will change
john 14 let's read from verse 8. what does it say
philip says unto him what lord show us
the father and it sufficeth us verse 9
jesus said unto him have i been so long time with
you and yet hast thou not known me philip he that
have seen me have seen the father and how saves
thou then shows the father believeth thou not that
i am in the father and the father in me now you
read with me now microscopically the words come
on that i speak unto you i speak not of myself
but the father dwelleth in me he does the works
it is he speaking through me and telling
speaking through me and saying repent
for the kingdom of heaven is at hand so the
message of repent even from john the baptist
came right from the throne of god because he
was the one who had to send his son for sin
one more verse verse 24 of john 14 read it with
me he thou loveth me not keepeth not my sayings
and the word which he hear come on is not mine
finish the verse but the father which sent me
now i hope you're convinced that everything jesus
said the father told him to say it if that's clear
say amen now listen to jesus again from that time
began jesus to speak and to preach and to say what
repent why for the kingdom of heaven is at hand
who was sending that message god the father
that's the highest authority in the universe the
father is higher than the sun in authority not
in essence they're all divine all divine but in
authority you see here's the father here's the son
here's the holy ghost they're all divine but with
respect to authority on position they're like that
can you see these fingers this is the way they are
in essence and substance equal but in authority
they're this that's the holy ghost that's jesus as
the father so jesus can say my father is greater
than i not more god than i he has more authority
are you following me all right john the baptist
preached what jesus preached what go to mark six
or subject what is it present truth in all ages
mark 6 3 verse 7 and verse 12.
mark chapter 6 who has said lord put your words in
that man's mouth who has said that prayer ah thank
you thank you thank you the rest of you hurry up
and say it mark 6 reading verse 7 what does this
say and he called unto him the twelve and began
to send them forth by two and two and gave them
power over unclean spirits read verse 12 and they
went out come on and preach that men should repent
that's the summary of what they had to
say repent because the problem is sin
the bible doesn't say they went out
and preached that men should get rich
now get me don't misunderstand me i'm not against
money money is a blessing it's a talent tremendous
tool for easing suffering but that's not why jesus
died that's my point he did not die because i'm
poor he did not die because you're single he
did not die because you did not finish the ged
tell me why he died one word sin selling drugs
breaking into banks robbing people gambling
lying cheating on my taxes that's why he died
and with a natural inability to
obey god that power called sin
john the baptist said repent jesus said repent the
disciples said repent while he was on the earth
that's what they preach because he could
check them and say no no don't say that but
they said repent but what did they say after
he left you see when the cat is away the mice
will play are you following me when jesus left
what did the disciples say go to acts chapter 2
acts chapter 2 we'll read from verse 37 and 38 our
subject present truth in all ages it's ten to one
we have a few minutes left we have a
meeting at 3 30 one at five i believe
one at six so it's a long day and we want to leave
time for physical food can you say amen for that
all right what book did i say acts what
chapter 2 what verses 37 38 read with me
now when they heard this they were preached
in their heart and said unto peter and to the
rest of the apostles men and brethren what
shall we do now they listened to a sermon
on the day of pentecost they were convicted
and the question was what shall by the way
people are frequently asking jesus what must i do
now we live in a world where
everyone says just believe
just believe the rich young ruler said what must
i do the jailer of philip i said what must i do
paul when he met jesus on the
road to damascus what must i do
the man who listened to peter
on pentecost what shall we do
listen to me there is a doing associated with
your salvation not just believe believe belief
stop going to that woman's house
at midnight or any other time
stop stealing do something stop it make a decision
now give you power to exercise that choice
what shall we do then peter said unto
them repent be baptized every one of you
in the name of jesus christ for the remission
of sins and you shall receive the gift
of the holy ghost repent now john the
baptist said what jesus said what the
disciples while christ was on earth said what
the disciples when christ left said what repent
how far back will sin go on the earth
adam and eve where did they live in the garnet
before they exited there was sin in the
garden of eden let's go to genesis 2.
i can never read that passage enough what
verses do you think i'll point you to 16 and
17. i want you to read those
two verses without looking
don't look at the bible say them
you must know these verses but of course you
need to peak a little okay genesis 2 16 17. are
you ready let me know by saying ml read with
me and the lord god commanded the man saying
of every tree of the garden thou mayest freely
eat but of the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil thou shalt not eat of it for in the day
thou it is thereof thou shall surely die stop
the last word of verse 17 die listen to romans 5
12. let's go there romans 5 12 keep the word die
in your mind it is first used by god thou shalt
surely die what's the only reason why people die
let us go to romans 5 verse 12. when you found
it say amen read with me what does it say
wherefore as by one man come on sin entered
into the world and death by sin stop
so when god told adam if you eat you'll die
what did god mean by if you eat if you sin
the only reason people die is because of sin
let me say something you may find difficult
to believe at first people don't die of cancer
they die from sin
cancer is just an expression of sin
the servant of the lord tells us
all sickness is the result of sin
so god told adam if the day you sin
because sin is disobedience you will die but the
devil said no in the day you sin you will live
that's why he said eat and people believe that
up to this day the way to
be blessed is to disobey god
and so sin goes all the way back to eden now let's
go to chapter three and let's read verses six
seven and eight chapter 3 6 7 and
8 present truth in all ages 5 to 1.
if i need an extra 10 minutes can i have them say
yes all right genesis 3 reading from verse 6. read
with me you haven't found genesis 3 yet okay all
right i thought it was so challenging but okay
do you have it now genesis 3 from verse 6 read
with the preacher what does this say and when the
woman saw that the tree was good for food and
that it was pleasant to the eyes and the tree
to be desired to make one wise she took of the
fruit thereof and didn't eat and gave also unto
her husband with her and he didn't eat next verse
and the eyes of them both were opened and they
knew that they were naked and they saw fig leaves
together and made themselves aprons next verse
and they heard the voice of the lord god walking
in the garden in the cool of the day and adam
and his wife hid themselves from the presence of
the lord god amongst the trees of the garden stop
when they realize when they sin at verse 6
they realize they were naked what did they do
they cover themselves with leaves aprons now i
want you to look closely well let's go to verse
21 first of genesis 3. read with me and to adam
also and to his wife did the lord god make coats
of skins and clothed them let's look at the two
verses 7 and 21. before i do let's pray again
holy father in heaven if i have said
anything i shouldn't have said forgive me
now give me more of your spirit as i come to
the conclusion because the last thing i say
may be what people take away so be
with me now god bless those listening
impressed in person and via internet in jesus
name i pray amen listen to seven read with me now
and the eyes of them both were open now before
we read the verse completely we're looking for
pronouns he she them they are sweet are you with
me all right tell me how many pronouns you find
in uh that verse not only pronouns but names
and pronouns read with me now and the eyes of
them both we have the kid both as well were opened
and they knew that they were naked and they sewed
fig leaves together and made themselves aprons how
many pronouns did we find six referring to whom
adam come on and who else adam and eve
and who else adam and eve and who else
where do you see the devil show me adam and eve
and who else nobody else nobody else in that verse
listen to the verse again and the eyes of them
both who was that were opened and they knew who
was that that they were naked who's there and they
saw fig leaves who was there made themselves who's
that imprint nobody else the devil can't make you
sin are you with me he didn't point a gun at eve's
head or at jesus's head in the wilderness
he said jesus if you don't mind please sin
that's the way he functions sin is an invitation
or temptation is an invitation sin is saying yes
or no now having read verse 7 listen to verse
21 let's pick out the nouns and pronouns are you
ready read with me unto adam also and to his wife
made the lord cultural skins and clothed them how
many pronouns are nouns five how many people are
in that verse three name them adam eve and god now
what's going on in that verse that we have adam
even god but we do not have god in verse seven
what's happening in seven
they're separated from god in seven and they're
doing well they're taking care of their sins how
in their own way god has nothing to do with that
but in verse 21 where forgiveness has taken place
we don't have leaves in 21 we have skins that came
from animals and according to leviticus chapter
one it's always the sinner that kills the animal
not god adam killed that animal in the garden
not god as i've heard some people say not god
there's bloodshed adam and eve can't be forced by
god remember he's a god of choice they accept him
you see when god when they heard the voice
of god in verse 8 they ran but now they're
in god's presence they must have come back so
we're reasoning through the scriptures they
have come back they've accepted the coats and god
has removed the aprons of leaves how do we knew
you know he removed the aprons because in
zechariah chapter three there god said take
away the filthy garments from him and unto him
he said i will cause thy iniquity pass from thee
i will clothe you with change of raymond
something has to be removed and something put on
in verse 21 we have forgiveness
we have conversion or we have justification
by faith god is dealing with sin
that's all he's dealing with sin
that's all he deals with from then until now sin
so adam and eve while the word
is not mentioned they clearly
repented of their sins are you following me
because to be clothed with the covering of
christ is to accept the righteousness of christ
revelation 16 15 behold i come as a thief blessed
is he that watcheth and keepeth his garments lest
he walk naked and they see his shame i remember
revelation 3 verse 18 i counsel thee by of me gold
tried in the fire that always be rich and a white
rhymer that thou makes me clothed and that the
shame of thy nakedness do not appear the white
linen of the saints is the righteousness of christ
revelation 19 verse 8. so it was the righteousness
of christ represented by those coats of skin god
was dealing with sin adam and eve had repented
so christ came and said john the baptist said
repent who told him to say that jesus preached
repent who told him to say that the apostles
preached repent when christ was on earth who
told them to say that they preached repent when
christ was gone back who told them to say that
repent repent consistently because
repentance is present truth in every age
the three angels messages was not present truth
in the days of noah or jeremiah or isaiah it's
present truth now are you listening to me
it's present truth now the commandments of
god and the faith of jesus but repentance is
present truth in every age of earth's history
let me demonstrate that biblically for you go to
revelation 2. revelation 2 we'll read verse 5.
well let's read 4-5 this is the message
to the church where at ephesus what are
the seven churches to whom christ sent seven
letters name them in order without looking
this is an adventist church i believe name
them first church second one the third one
this mic is not working ephesus
smyrna pergamos thyatira
sardis philadelphia laodicea which one applies to
us okay so in revelation 2 4 and 5 read with me
nevertheless i have someone against the y because
that has left thy first love not lost left are you
with me a lot of people leave their first love
they don't lose they leave it read verse five
remember therefore from whence that might fall on
and repent stop what church is represented by the
church of ephesus prophetically the first century
of the earth of the christian church represented
by a white horse that is the early the apostolic
church set up by christ and the message is repent
go to revelation 3
this is the very last church name that church
leoducia you read verse 19 of revelation 3 our
subject present truth in every age revelation 3
verse 19. when you found it say amen read with me
as many as i love i rebuke and chase him come on
be zealous therefore and repent now we have a 2
000 year period in the days of the apostles
repent today two thousand years later repent
five after one i have ten minutes
i don't mean to be hard i just need to be direct
keep in mind every time i preach i'm
preaching twice i've preached to myself
then i preach it to you or whoever is
listening your problem and mine is sin
it is not the pastor
it is not the conference now we you see
should i yeah i'll tell you go to genesis
3 let's explain why it is not the conference
or the pastor or even your spouse it's you
genesis 3 let's read from verse 9.
when he found it say amen read with me and the
lord god called unto adam and said unto him
whereas thou and he said i
heard thy voice in the garden
and i was afraid because i was naked and i hid
myself now that's personal i heard your voice
i was afraid come on i was naked i
hid myself he didn't say eve hid me
no one can make you sin
even with a gun to your head
you can choose death over sin daniel chose it
the three hero boys chose it jesus chose it
christians need to realize you
have a choice and the choice is die
i heard thy voice in the garden of genesis 3
10 and i was afraid because i was naked and
i hid myself verse 11 and he said who told thee
that thou was naked hast thou eaten of the tree
whereof i commanded thee thou should not eat
read verse 12 and the man said the woman whom
now gave us to be with me she gave me of the
tree and i did eat what game is he playing
the blame game says you sound like an expert the
blame game huh that is the result of sin a sinner
naturally blames someone else for everything
that's bad and takes credit for what's good
ah you're not listening i'm talking to myself
listen to the woman verse 13 and the lord god said
unto the woman what is this that thou has done
finish the verse a woman said the serpent beguiled
me and i did worse than that is genetic now
not me but you have the thing in your
head the knife with the blood not me
this is serious
well i don't have time to preach this but let me
tell you now briefly that's the problem with the
law and obedience the sinner blames the law
for being too hard and so they say change it
but what's really hard come on this not the
law this but sin has given us the blame game
mindset and so we've got to blame anyone
except me so we blame the law change it
and i'll keep it what does the bible say the
law is not grievous their commandments are
not grievous meaning heart or burdensome
if they're not grievous they are easy
this is hard but because i'm a sinner i
can't confess i am no good so i blame the
law that the bible describes as holy just good
spiritual psalm 1907 perfect so i can't keep the
seventh-day sabbath too hard no the bible
says it's easy if you let god change this
so adam said that woman and
the woman said that's an ape
that's why we blame the pastor
i fast twice a week i give tithes
of all i possess you remember
the pharisee in luke 18. it
can't be me it's the pastor
it's the deacon
it's my husband doesn't talk to
me it's the conference they have
some guys on the conference committee that believe
in a in a spiritual formation it's their fault
no finish my words it's your fault
and mine and so i say again our problem is sin
there is something we're doing we need to stop
all the soy milk will be useless
all the veggie links as good as
they are and the smoothies no value
eternally because there's something you're
holding on that's working against the soymilk
sin listen to me the human heart is so hard
some people only confess sin on the death bed
only when they see death okay i was
wrong that's how stubborn we are
are we on the church board we're
on the conference committee
we do this we do that but we will not let go sin
and so the pastor can't preach and the
church doesn't have a nice enough parking lot
and they don't have programs for my
children and this and that and that
but no one turns a finger and
says the problem is sin in my life
today god the father is speaking to you through
john the baptist jesus and the apostles of course
his word give me one word that the father
is saying to you unto me right now repent
let's do that
if you don't need a degree
from the university of maryland
to understand what the bible
wants stop doing what you're doing
let me explain it this way you go to the doctor
and you complain of chest problems you can't
breathe the doctor examines you and he notices
spots on your lung and he sees a bulge in your
top pocket virginia slims what does he tell you
stop smoking in other words stop doing the thing
that's killing you he can't tell you switch brands
are you with me commit smaller sins or don't
sin so often and sin only on the weekends stop
if he doesn't say that he needs to have his
license revoked or she you're going to the doctor
you complain of your liver he examines you and
he sees the initial stages of cirrhosis of the
liver and he sees a brown paper bag bulging
out of your back pocket your levi jeans
and he smells the perfume on your breath the
alcoholic perfume what does he tell you stop
drinking he can say go from bourbon to whiskey
stop drinking because you are killing yourself
listen to me the man or the woman who holds on to
sin finish my words is killing himself or herself
and most of us do it gladly with the
look of pride i am the man i am the woman
sin has made us suicidal
father out of love isn't repent a message of love
stop doing what you're doing correct your
swing so you stop missing all the time
and today god tells us as i say for the second
time or third or fourth let's repent turn away
turn away ask god to help us to turn away we
must make the choice he provides the power are
you with me but you see this desk let's say i
try to lift it with one hand and i can't lift
it and i try i can't lift it that's my sin you
see i can't move and i pray the gods of father
through your word the word that said let there be
light and there was light through your powerful
word in my heart give me the victory over this sin
i still have to try to lift are you following me
now when i do that now divine power is combined
with my human effort and the thing comes
but most of us say lord move it
you move it because you committed
it but i'll give you the power
combine it with your your effort and
you will experience the victory identify
in your mind an island mine what is it we need
to repent of right now where we sit or stand
there's at least one thing make
up your mind right now to stop
and see the change in your life mental
spiritual your conscience clears a bell
your immune system's strengthened nothing
suppresses the immune system like sin
and guilt i'm always looking around
present truth in all ages from eden till now
my brothers and sisters when i leave this desk
i want to be able to say to god father i told
him as directly as i could without being rude
and i reminded myself i cannot be held
responsible for anyone who leaves and
still holds on to whatever is killing him
or her i am not responsible as paul said
wherefore i take you to declare this day that i
am pure from the blood of all men who will say
father i need victory over something and i want
that victory to start today because your son
died because of that weakness of mine forget
other people christ died for you that's why he
went looking for one sheep in the parable of the
shepherd who lost one out of a hundred christ died
for you not just the world so who will say father
there's something i need to conquer i am willing
i need help can i see your right hand stand
up with me serious people stand up i need help
in genesis 11 don't go there just listen when god
observed the building of the tower of babel by the
the men and the women who built it the bible says
and the lord came down to see the tower of the
city which the children of men build in genesis
11 5 and lord said behold the people is one
and they have all one language
and this they begin to do
and now nothing will be restrained from them
which they have imagined in other words they
are determined to build that temple and if divine
power doesn't stop them no power can stop them
they were so determined now why am i saying that
let's tell god i am determined to conquer that sin
and no power from hell will stop me
i am determined to break that habit
that you've identified in your mind heads bowed
eyes closed father in heaven we come to you in
the name of jesus who was severely tempted and
resisted in your strength through faith in your
word as we are to do we thank you for the message
that god present truth in all ages now father for
those of us whose hearts have been touched and
there's genuine conviction going on right now
we have all stood the pulpit and the pew to say
there's something i need to stop it may be small
their father it may be huge it makes no difference
because what adam did was just to eat a fruit
and that's not big but it would have destroyed
him had he not confessed and so father we say to
you lord we want to break this habit we want
to cast out that thing that is killing us a
spiritual condition is not the pastor's fault
it is not the conference's fault it is not our
spices spouse's fault it is our fault because
we're not six or five years old we're adults
and while heads about their eyes are closed as
i make this call to god let your spirit work
vigorously here's bad eyes closed is there
someone who needs to come back to jesus
you were close and you drifted
he never shoved you away
you drifted you know you have this
is no guesswork you know you have
and you will say today father i am coming back
i want to be close where is safe with my savior
and by his grace never leave him again if
you have drifted and you want to come back
come to the front you've drifted
not made a mistake you've drifted
you want to come back seriously come to the
front i've drifted this is serious business now
there has been a trend of departure from god
as i review my past 18 24 months three years
i have drifted from god i want to come back come
to the front just come down if it applies to you
come to the front you weren't killing people you
weren't robbing banks but you know in your heart
you've drifted from god god bless you my
brother come to the front you know in the book
great controversy page 549 paragraph two ella
white writes many a man of cultured intellect
and pleasing manners who would not stoop to
what is ordinarily regarded as an immortal act
is but a polished instrument in the hands of
satan no you're not a murderer bank robber but
you've drifted in every other area of your
life come say father i'm coming back come
there are a lot of polite people who belong to the
devil very nice and talented and polished and the
devil's servants come i'll give you 60 seconds to
come they begin now the call is i know in my heart
i have drifted from god as i examined my life
i'm coming back come god bless you sister
god bless you 45 seconds this is serious
you may say let me wait for the next service well
the next service will not be exactly like this
the spirit doesn't work the same way
twice all the time in the same life
this is the service the lord sent you to
come 30 seconds i have drifted from god
the people who said crucify him were all in
church but they couldn't be any farther from god
20 seconds i've drifted i'm
coming back come be serious
as the spirit of god talks
to your heart 10 seconds
then i have a second question to ask before i
pray second question is someone who you want to
make a decision to be baptized or re-baptized
because of your past life baptized or re-baptized
you'd like to make that decision now not saturday
just make the decision publicly let god know you
are willing to be baptized or re-baptized let me
see your hand if there's someone like that willing
to be baptized or re-baptized just raise your hand
i'll also give you 60 seconds and i pray for
both groups willing to be baptized or re-baptized
evangelism page 375 paragraph 2 the servant of
the lord writes when a soul is truly reconverted
let that soul be rebaptized let him renew his
covenant with god and god will renew his covenant
with him reconversion must take place in the
churches 30 seconds baptism read baptism god
bless you have a hand i need someone who writes
the names i have another hand another hand god
bless you god bless you now i need come come don't
be afraid come you raise your hand for baptismally
baptism come come i want you separate from the
other group come come quickly i'll pray let you
go come someone come and take names i want copies
of the name so i can pray for you myself come
yeah baptism or re-baptism to the right or to my
left and over to the right start with god again
this time get it right by his abiding power 15
seconds left baptism rebaptism before i pray
first call was i have drifted from my god and
i'm coming back second call i feel convicted to
make a decision to be baptized or re-baptized i
have no date but i want god to see i am willing
to take that step that's the second call 10
seconds on that then i pray i want these names
do we have them are we getting them for
those for baptism or re-baptism we have
my brother right here the marathion then
my brother and sister over to my right
these decisions must be taken very seriously
okay just before the names let's pray
i'll pray first for the first group father you
led me to call for those who've drifted from you
they got in heaven remember the parable of the
prodigal boy that jesus spoke at your instruction
every day the father looked and looked and looked
when he saw the boy stumbling up the path he ran
to meet him let your sons and daughters who've
answered the call to return to you let them know
that your arms are wide open there's
rejoicing in heaven and as you wrap your
arms around them draw them to your bosom
they god let them feel that divine heart
beating with excitement for their return and
with that return god let them make up their minds
i don't want to drift from my savior again
because the next time i may never come back
please god those who made decisions
for baptism or re-baptism bless them
let them decide i am resuming my walk with
my savior and i want to fulfill amos 3 3 can
two walk together except to be agreed and for my
savior and i to agree i have to do things his way
and so bless this second group they god and just
before i close father i pause for the last time
who else will say i have drifted far from
god and i need to come back who else will
say i am deciding for baptism or rebaptism
in the last 15 seconds raise your hand
baptism come sister come come come baptism read
baptism come please get that name for me please
the call also i've drifted from
god and i want to come back
five seconds
father in heaven i made a human effort to
represent you if i was weak in that forgive me
but your spirit is all-powerful let the
spirit now take this puny effort of mine
father shape this message like a needle and
prick the hearts that need that conviction
let no one leave this building without
making a decision based on what they've heard
let no one cut off the internet who may be
listening without making a decision to repent
and come back to god fill our hearts their
god with the consciousness of the shortness
of the time in which we live fill our minds with
the consciousness of the deadly nature of sin
now father give us a love for righteousness
bless every family every individual every
man woman boy and girl in this building along
the internet father with every day that passes
let us seek to draw closer to your
presence here is humble pray day god
when you come into your kingdom save all
of us and those who've come to know you
through our holy influence i pray in jesus
name let god's people say amen and immensely